this story went viral and I have no idea
why about this Tennessee cop Megan Hall
she's now claiming she was sexually
groomed and that she said no and they
wouldn't take no for an answer or like
one guy wouldn't or something like that
they colluded in their authority to
systematically disarm her resistance and
entrap her in degrading in in an abusive
relation sexual relationships exploiting
her felt trapped so you want to talk
about guys in the modern era if a dude
is with a girl and the girl comes up to
him and puts her hands on his shoulder
and leans in for a kiss and kisses him
he just assaulted her and if she wants
and she says it they're in trouble this
is a story that went viral for months
about a woman who was banging a bunch of
cops and just was as Loose as loose can
get and now she's claiming she was
victimized and they wouldn't let her
they wouldn't so what did she say that
it was one that I mean so she was fine
with the other seven and not well she's
saying she was groomed she was saying
they they groomed her
yeah if you're an adult are you are you
getting groomed really no is that an
adult police officer is now complaining
about being grouped in all honesty
you're supposed to be the law
enforcement of the land like turn those
guys in what the hell's go you're a
grown adult professional with
professional equals quote I did say no
and he wouldn't take it for an answer
okay so is this that sounds like one is
this a story about this cop who was
being abused this female cop and just
didn't know what to do or is she a wild
and crazy cop who's hooking up see see
do we know I don't know I'll tell you
this if you've got a young guy
even if he asks if she can just say she
he didn't and then he's he's going to
jail he's getting locked up it is very
scary and like you know I have younger
brothers I have a son it is scary for
them dating now and Chappelle talked
about this with uh he did that joke
where he had the guy sign a consent for
hit part of consent form and then he was
just like now hold on there he climbs
off him and he's like let me just just
fill that out initial here and sign here
and just make sure everything's good
because that's where things were going
and the funny thing is that show was
like early 2000s and then it was the
2010s when we got mattress girl this
woman who begs a dude to hook up with
her reportedly and he doesn't want to be
with her finally they hook up then he
leaves and he's like I don't want to be
with you she gets mad about it and then
carries her matches around claiming he
raped her even though the messages show
that she was begging him
so when Ian asks should a guy ask can I
kiss you yeah your best bet is meet a
girl at church and have a real
relationship and get married and all
that stuff otherwise you go to jail or
something but going to church to hook up
going to church no the confession Booth
no one can see it if I worship loud
enough what I'm saying is meet a person
in a real environment and have a real
relationship it's tough to do a lot of
it like uh what do they call it happen
stance like you walk by and you see her
like that not anymore dude now we got
that five hours of walking through New
York as a woman if you even say howdy
ma'am you're considered assault you're
assaulting your cat calling what about
that whole Home Depot thing I said to go
they said to go to Home Depot and find a
guy in Home Depot because the guy can
actually fix stuff oh so like there's a
good place to meet a man if a woman
wants to run into a married contractor
I went to theater school and I met other
actresses girls that I and that's how I
got my first real serious girlfriend
because I was pretty nerdy so look if
you're a woman
and you're not gonna take advise me I'm
some dude and you want to meet a guy go
to Home Depot and then just make sure
there's no ring on the on the hand and
then just you know say I'm trying to fix
a door can you help me can I hire you
really just need so many DIY projects
don't lie to your way into the
relationship but no like if you're at
Home Depot for a real reason you gotta
have a problem fixed you're gonna find a
better quality guy oh they're so happy
to help too every time I don't know what
to do I'm like I'm just gonna ask them
how to do it can you reach that they're
so happy to help there but not just that
like guys like solving problems and
being helpful if a woman goes to a guy
and says look I I gotta fix a door and I
need somebody who can help me do it you
know a guy might be like that sounds
great I could totally help you with that
that'd be awesome yeah I'm here to help
do you think that uh dating apps should
be deleted from people's phones or
should they keep I think it I think that
and social media contributes to the
problem of people always thinking
there's something else out there well
you know I could do better and that's
just comparative in general with the
lives that we're living but it
absolutely contributes to it I noticed
that I was in a relationship and I had
kept Tinder on my phone and I would
still find myself looking at it from
time to time well what if I need it you
know it's that hole it might be
something else and so this last
relationship I'm in right now I deleted
all the apps right away it was just I
knew like getting into it and what uh
there's uh you can always reinstall it
you know it's not like it's gone forever
let's make a fake dating app
where it's like all of the people on it
are Bots and they just they say nice
things too you know there's like a
conservative dating app now I don't
remember what it's called but like uh
Christian rights stuff write stuff it's
something like that but like that just
means you're gonna find hyper political
people who are just obsessed with
politics which is not what you want
either there's Christian Mingle right
yeah it's like it's been around for a
long time
Jay date I always part of me want to get
a J date I'm not even Jewish it feels so
dirty just like join us a Facebook group
of people who are interested in
something it was like a fantasy kind of
thing just like join a join a Facebook
group people are interested in things
and then go to things go to events
people need to talk to their neighbors
and find local community oh you meet
people through people that's a good way
to do it that's a great way to do it
until they used to okay so so think
about something something you're
interested in and then go to events of
those things and meet people the problem
is when it comes to a lot of when it
comes to a lot of of uh Hobbies or
crafts and stuff it's dudes it's not
women like true Ashley you're right
about arranged marriage
yeah I just wanted to put that out you
know you need to bring that back yeah
really those clutch what's your favorite
I mean think about it think about like
the The Stereotype of like the older
woman who is always trying to like match
make younger people that doesn't exist
anymore because she's bitter and single
she hates younger women she doesn't want
her to find love right okay that
archetype of the matchmaking woman in a
in a village you know it doesn't exist
anymore
probably because she has a family and
wants me to have a family the problem
the problem with arranged marriage is
that it's um it's anti-meritocratic in
that you might have a three-year-old boy
and a three-year-old girl and then
they're like we're gonna our kids are
gonna get married when they're older and
then by 18 the the male is like a
hundred pounds soaking wet frail they
were rarely arranged at such a young age
but it's not forced arranged marriage is
not forced marriage then how could it be
arranged you're allowing the parents to
judge the merits of the other person
yeah because they're older and more wise
so you're saying like when a woman is
about to become an adult or whatever the
parents decide oh we found this guy for
you get married to him like a guy's
parents are involved it's not full it's
not arranged the families are it's just
like a mom suggesting a guy like honey
you should marry the guy across the
street
families and working it out love is
about compromise anyway you know
I feel like the obsession with like
marrying for love as well is very hyper
individualistic yeah there's a lot of
different type of Love yeah and it's
kind of yeah you know
if you're like I love this sandwich so
much like what what kind of love I think
love is also a choice and not a feeling
in a lot of ways I think people too many
people equate it with a feeling that's
what I was saying like people like I
think our generation and younger are led
to believe because of movies that you
know you walk into a bar and there's
like a beautiful man that's like
I'm in love and it's just like yeah and
then you find out she's like a white
supremacist you know and you're like oh
I don't want to be here like she's
attractive but not I'm not going there
you know like you sounds like this has
happened to you no I just mean like you
see a beautiful woman and it turns out
she's just like messed up there could be
like a pretty lady and you're like wow
she's beautiful and then she's like the
people from the Moon have stolen my
cheese and you're like okay I'm getting
out of here or you know I don't know
maybe your guy was into that kind of
crazy wild ride maybe she was just
eating candies with Ian for a moment I
think doctor go to the Moon bro you find
someone that you have things in common
with where you can have fun you can get
along and you enjoy each other's company
and then over time you build a
relationship you said it was a choice so
like I had to find that I mean you
choose to love people I think
um even your family and people they they
don't always act in ways choose to will
the good of another yeah yeah so the
choice being like like you're letting
you're accepting the downsides of the
person yeah I mean as long as they're
not abusive or toxic
um all the crazy people just need to be
with each other and then leave all the
same people alone yeah there should be
like a crazy people dating app Oh you
mean all of them for all the rejects
yeah Tinder is one of the worst too what
are your favorites like what are your
top three I've never used them I had
Tinder Bumble and Okay Cupid did you
ever use any of those I was on Okie who
but a long time ago I got it at first
because I was building mines and I was
like we were gonna to add a Tinder thing
into the thing so me and Bill were like
hey market research let's get it and it
was so addictive I'd spent hours just
like swiping I'm like I and this is the
most superficial stuff I've ever done in
my life I'm judging these each
individual human we don't even need it
anymore with all the data we've
collected an AI can just be like boom
this is your match you're done the AI
I'm not even arranged okay yes like I
arranged I guarantee I guarantee you
this I would bet a large sum of money
that if you took all the data from all
the dating apps and then plugged in the
data to like an AI the AI could find
your match instance a Black Mirror yes
sir and then you'd be like because it
knows you're where you're from it knows
how old you are it knows how much you
weigh you could do like one of those
history I mean if you want to put that
generally but I'm saying you can't
account for your personality yes it can
because Okay Cupid does that thing where
it asks you all the questions it knows
when you poop so it can like be like oh
yeah Facebook
could do it Facebook check it out that's
what it was supposed to be Facebook
would understand things about you in in
weird ways like
you don't need to tell Facebook you're a
conservative Facebook can see your post
where you say manga2024 you don't need
to tell Facebook that you enjoy peanut
butter and jelly sandwiches because you
once posted posted an image of a blue
circle and it seems completely unrelated
but there will be weird things like that
where statistically people who like
peanut butter and jelly for some reason
are more likely to post blue circles
than red squares and we don't notice
those things but the AI will because
it's looking at hundreds of millions of
Internet interactions and then finding
statistical correlations so they already
do that there's um you know if you buy
turkey bacon you're more likely to vote
Democrat and these political parties
already use different data like that
that's really scary the amount of data
have you ever looked at your Google
profile yes yeah or if you drive a
Subaru you're more likely to vote
Democrats but be a lesbian yeah but
that's obvious that's like oh we get it
somebody who likes turkey bacon is more
likely be left leaning but what about
something like you you uh uh go to
McDonald's at seven in the morning oh
you're more likely to get oil changes in
the third of the month at 7 pm like
weird things that we can't see it will
find those correlations and tell you
that means in dating apps if it took
your social media profile all of your
data
we could easily at this point make an AI
that would be like here's your perfect
match I think we're getting it in terms
of attractiveness in terms of location
in terms of personality the AI would
break it all down and be like based on
the people you've messaged based on the
people she's messaged based on what you
like and don't like the times you go to
the bathroom and the food you eat you
should get married thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time